[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  as far as elon musk himself taking the  stake in this company i think it's  interesting from the perspective of you  know he's kind of been very vocal in  his uh stance about twitter i know this  is a passive state but i think um elon  musk will look to put some pressure here  on the board and potentially even um  look to take an actual stake without an  interest within the board  [Music]  he clearly wants to accomplish something  um by having a stake in the in the  company i think you know he's definitely  made um  comments saying he would potentially  look to start up his own social media  company by doing this in terms of taking  a stake in twitter and potentially you  know maybe the end game is acquiring the  company outright it would be a much  easier  endeavor to take than kind of starting  something up from scratch  [Music]